e aí galera jogador mozer a itabom que
bom e sábio carnaval gente eu sou uma
pessoa muito animados em começar pra
vocês que eu não sou uma pessoa assim
que eu gosto muito assim do paraná baixo
mas quem vai arrumar senhor brincar acho
bem interessante acho massa era boa que
me irrita é a pessoa que só fala em
carnaval 21 18 o doido já tenho um amigo
que acaba o último dia de carnaval ea
pensão carnaval do ano de 2016 o início
de 2016 não é tanto em sandomil 17 neve
bem atualizado acha pessoa encha o saco
e aparece morto e mais um carnaval do
outro angeles e claudia leitte léo
santana na máxima ivete sangalo e
claudia leitte junto não consegue
receber mais um game mas não tem nada
mas léo santana é muito louco real
tamanho da rua de lei para travar a
dormir em seus avaiano fantasmão é o
tchan machucar outra deixa puto meio ela
me disse 'não esse ano no carnaval eu
vou ficar com ninguém não é esse ano não
quero ficar ninguém é seu não quero nem
só para divertir a brincar a brincar
esse ano se ela dança louca sozinha só
no primeiro dia de carnaval termina à
noite e ficou com 4 1781 porque disse é
para ser assim e aí como é que vai ser o
carnaval não sei pronto subtende e no
carnaval a pessoa fica na avenida noé
trio é muita gente e esse lugar que tem
muita gente eu não sou assim a melhor
pessoas ou de pessoa a pessoa chega pra
mim ela fala comigo fica assim nervoso
eu não sei puxar sim eu sou o tipo de
pessoa que quando não tenho que
conversar com a pessoa eu pergunto pra
ela como se deu o tratado de tordesilhas
só assim eu não sei conversar então
lugar que não me favorece muito o
carnaval tem seu fim encostado no muro
só olhando eu e você também não está com
muita condição financeira a bebida é
muito cara cheio na china a cerveja eu
tiro as cervejas bom assim que eu faço o
dia da cerveja tiras e meio tudo bom
homem enquanto ela chega espinha tudo
bom sim
enquanto que a copa é bom é 7 reais
quer dizer se não é só aquela máquina
realizou por todo é de r$7 mesmo assim o
técnico latim e brancos nem ai ela teve
sol r$7 ela tinha skol 7 50 e é lá que
ele ai 5 é o quem não nada não vai
querer um gol e não deixá-la é você não
tem condição financeira para tomar um
outro qualquer se faz é obrigado a dar
uns pegas na china cerveja poderia
liberar cerveja de graça quem já pegou o
dia da cerveja não tomou ainda no
carnaval e no carnaval tem aquela
pegação aquela coisa que todo mundo
andar do tavira ou beijo na boca ir o
postulado beijo na boca é bom é bom
agora muito lado não morta uma coisa que
é o q2 abc até tenta evitar de down vez
na minha a mudança diz assim ela pode
pesar não tenha boqueira não aitolá e
beija beija o pé não beijar jeans oyston
gente tome cuidado no carnaval se você
aí vai abrir folga você tome cuidado com
esse negócio de doença com essa é coisa
séria aires ae consegue nunca vai ver
uma pessoa desse menino do peão a aids
viu o filme derrubou a não sabe se você
quiser assistir no facebook que se fala
no facebook em um amplo leque gols
clique em curtir no facebook marca os
amigos são os comentários podem ver aqui
no youtube que você faz se deixa que ele
gostei que a ajuda de mais a gente muito
medo ea primeira vez e também meus
vídeos só tem servido meu canal para
nunca perder nenhum virou me assistir
acho que tem olha você assistir se viu
até aqui falou e nós e se derrubarem nós
nós levantar de novo porque hoje nós é
um milhão de bicho solto